[Music]
hey what's up guys this is just an
unboxing video it's just a little quick
video but it's the first giveaway I've
ever won on YouTube and the link to the
person who actually won his giveaway is
in the description he does have a lot of
Giveaways so first of all I'm just going
to just open up the case real quick it's
the music skins I believe so I let's
just get right into it and I see it
shipped in I'm a huge overseas so it did
take a while
here's a little notes and here are the
actual music schemes the raps so this
for the iPod Touch and I do after what
you guys knew that I do not have an iPod
Touch as of today so these could be a
giveaway video and there's a little note
here so let's see if I can grasp on
winning my giveaway thanks for
subscribing hopefully you make an
unboxing video and please give a shout
out so yeah there's a shout out his link
is in the description and I hope you
like maybe I'll do a giveaway of this
case or maybe I'll do some more reviews
maybe I'll get someone's iPod Touch so I
can show you guys the installation and
everything so I want to thank you for
the cases check out a link in the
description that is this is going to be
the first series of a shout out of the
cool new tech channel of the week so if
you the best chance of getting a shout
out for the tech channel of the week is
to not ask but I'm really this this guy
in the description he does have a lot of
videos you get more subscribers and this
is a really good on really good thing
that I want so thanks for sending me
these reps and hopefully gets you guys
later
so that check out the cool new tech
channel tech channel of the week and
that is it for this video please